a concept paper revealed the lady was
not for tanning the problematic private
arbitration clause under t tip isds was
still on the table but a few tweaks more
state protection and a joint eu-us
arbitration body would be set up hand EU
Trade Commission Cecilia Malstrom
offered enough sir positive step in the
right direction and it's also clear that
the old fashioned isds instrument is
none longer adequate for modern trade
policy on the other hand the scope for
investment called are too broad in my
opinion and she took a seat miss
Malstrom underlying these were not just
cosmetic changes and gave her reasons
for sticking by the investor state
dispute mechanism the u.s. have never
integrated any international law in
domestic legal system it will put
European companies in a disadvantage and
there are cases where there can be
discrimination there can be licenses
expropriation that is done in a
discriminatory way despite that other
still went warming to asds Voon efectos
opala dimostrazione dosa guapo Koivu
asds ontolo of air canada ases on
colorado elicit asmodian lucy do dis pas
besoin de SDS portela freedom st small
needed or not isds looks at to stay but
the rumblings over how to reform it will
continue